well the 2020 Democratic fanatics have
renewed their calls for reparations
while kissing the ring of the river nail
at the National Action Network
convention this week I would sign that
into law I firmly support congresswoman
Jackson Lee's bill to create a
commission to study reparations now is
Michael Meyers former ACLU national
board member now Michael you say that
this is all a scam explain of course it
is this it's more than that Blaine
whitey movement mania madness is a sheer
racial rhetoric and that's what you get
at the our show opt-in so-called house
of justice you have buffoonery and you
have diversion you have distraction you
have this notion of force so at that
house of so-called justice you have
either a horror picture show showing or
you have a sauce either way it is not to
be taken seriously I can't understand
how serious the presidential contenders
can give legitimacy to a ratio below
heart and I think it is outrageous and
silly and idiocy on the part of the
presidential candidates and anybody who
thinks that white Americans are going to
take the blame or going to feel guilty
or give their land and their property
away in some sort of reparations pot
because they feel responsibility for the
sins of their forebears they're not now
Sharpton was also trying to address the
improvements in the in the economic
standing of african-americans just in
the last two years and he just
missed it let's watch blacks are still
double unemployed the whites
you know Trump keeps saying it's the
lowest black unemployment ever was yeah
but we're still doubled the whites how
do you close the race gap how do you
close the race Gavin well so it doesn't
mean Trump literally cure cancer
tomorrow and Al Sharpton said yeah but
he should have done it you know a year
ago I can't I cannot take out Sharpton
seriously is the whole racial movement
is anti-intellectual its unintelligent
so I can't take before we 2020
candidates I mean one after the other
just prostrating themselves to kissing
his ring kissing his butt I just don't
get it if they want to be serious they
should take our shoppers and say no
that's not going to be any reparations
they're not gonna be steady your
reparations where is just reparations
PAC coming from James Forman in 1969
he'd went to the Riverside Church and
said we want 500 million that's all 500
million dollars at a reparation pot and
they wanted from the white churches and
the white synagogues well where did that
money go to it didn't go to black people
or the all the descendants are ever
conceived you know where that money goes
goes to it goes to two people who are
hustlers who are pimps and I resent it
and I think it's shameless and it's
racial idiocy and people who have sense
who are intelligent must address this as
such I think I mean I heard a lot of
people today we're saying what they're
doing is racist because you're actually
saying the guy who just came here from
Serbia six months ago somehow was gonna
have to write a check for a Somali
refugee who came here 20 years ago I
mean none of that makes any sense to
most people that's why I say it's other
intelligence nobody's giving up their
house nobody's giving up their land
nobody's giving away acres the 40 acres
are gone and and nobody not even a
building is going into that in that
reparation spot so what are they talking
about these people think they are
chasing a farce it's a campaign issue
this is just this is all power to
describe it yes it's a total distraction
it's before you back well the talking
we're gonna come you back to talk about
what the ACLU is doing
today's ACLU doing it lost it we didn't
have time to do it in this segment we
will have you back because it's
fascinating